and so it begins good morning heck it's
tuesday i do get why people dislike
sports as noted in a previous
anthropocene reviewed episode it's a
little weird that humans invest such a
tremendous portion of their limited
resources into developing
extremely sophisticated strategies for
placing a
usually round object into a hole or
through a hoop or
past a line and it's weird that so many
people offer gobs of their precious
attention to
watching and arguing over the exploits
of these balls and the people who get
paid astonishing sums of money to
move the balls around i get it but i
think deep down sports are not actually
about the balls or the people
maneuvering them i think at their core
sports are just a third thing i should
back up here and introduce you to the
third thing an essay the poet donald
hall wrote after the death of his wife
the poet jane kenyon
in the essay he writes we did not spend
our days gazing into each other's eyes
we did that gazing when we made love or
when one of us was in trouble
but most of the time our gazes met and
entwined as they looked at a third
thing third things are essential to
marriages
objects or practices or habits or arts
or institutions or games or human beings
that provide
a site of joint rapture and contentment
each member of a couple is separate the
two come together
in double attention i think these third
things are essential not only to
marriages but also to lots of other
relationships like
bts could be a third thing in a
friendship or
a youtube channel could be a third thing
in a sibling relationship and i think
larger communities also benefit from
third things that can offer a site of
joint rapture
and when sports work that's what they do
i think that might be why i am so
enthralled with afc wimbledon the third
tier english football team we sponsor
beginning in the 1990s wimbledon fans
suffered a series of heartbreaks that
had nothing to do with what was
happening to the balls or the people
moving them around
first they lost their stadium plow lane
before eventually being told that their
football club founded in 1889
basically no longer existed the club's
wealthy owners moved the team to milton
keynes and
wimbledon fans were left without their
third thing
but the fans just refused to accept that
so they reformed their club starting out
in the ninth tier of english football
now owned not by some rich person but by
the fans themselves the people who
valued wimbledon not as a financial
asset
but as a site of joint rapture each fan
pays about 30
a year for an ownership stake or less if
you're unemployed or retired or a
student and you can also pay
more and get perks like for instance
seeing your logo on the back of afc
wimbledon shorts but no matter how much
or how little you pay
you still get the same single vote in
board elections and other major
decisions
and with that model afc wimbledon have
worked their way from the bottom rungs
of amateur football back to being a
full-time professional team that
actually
now plays in the same division as that
franchise over in milton keynes
and this year afc wimbledon is at last
coming home
to a new stadium across the street from
where the old plow lane stadium stood
for decades wimbledon fans have been
singing show me the way to plow lane
i'm tired and i want to go home and now
they are going home at last and they are
going home
together that's the way to plow lane
together in milton keynes and in most of
the sporting world including at my
beloved liverpool football club we see a
model where third things are treated as
investment vehicles to be owned by the
rich and in wimbledon we see a very
different model one that treats the
third thing as belonging to
the people whose shared attention makes
that third thing valuable
wimbledon's way is definitely messier
and less efficient
but it's our club it really is ours
every one of us who cares about it
every fan should be so lucky hank i'll
see you on friday